are you patiently waiting for the next
PlayStation Plus games to get revealed
well then today's your lucky day as one
of april's free games for the ps4 has
been announced I'm Matt this is a game
spot news update and make sure to LIKE
and subscribe to stay up to date on all
of the free playstation plus games
multiplayer shooter drawn to death is
the first PlayStation Plus game to be
revealed for April it's from the creator
of God of War and twisted metal and
features an art style that might remind
you of your high school sketchbook I'm
not super excited to try this game out
for myself but I appreciate that
PlayStation Plus gives me a chance to
try out games that I normally wouldn't
I'll save any type of judgement until
next month drawn to death becomes
available to all PlayStation Plus
subscribers for free on April fourth and
those who aren't a member will be able
to pick it up on the same day for twenty
dollars we got the chance to talk to
creator david jaffe last year and he
explained why drawn to death doesn't
adopt things like leveling up and
upgrading that are so common in
multiplayer shooters these days you can
check out that interview on gamespot com
but if you want to watch some
multiplayer action check out our video
on everything you should know about
battlefield ones first expansion they
shall not pass
you
[Music]